bonsoir monsieur girard bonsoir vous
avez dit que le québec aura pleine
compensation financière avec droit de
retrait sans condition dans le dossier
des garderies mais vous avez dit qu'il
faut quand même négocier ça veut dire
quoi exactement
mais ça veut dire qu'il y est d'ailleurs
toujours des étapes
lorsqu'il ya des annonces budgétaires
comme celle ci d'abord le budget fédéral
doit être adopté ensuite le fédéral doit
signer une entente avec chacune des
provinces et et dans notre corps puisque
nous sommes l'inspiration du programme
pour le fédéral ce sera une entente
asymétrique qui reconnaît pleinement la
compétence du québec et
évidemment ce sera basé sur la
proportion des enfants possiblement de
50 mo et le plus tôt que le poids de la
population canadienne ce qui lui donne
une approximation way 2,6 milliards
c'est ça voilà sur 5 à 6 milliards de
dollars se dit ce montant là était pas
dans le budget il doit encore être
négocié en quelque part mais ça dit que
le budget c'est la politique budgétaire
du gouvernement fédéral
elle doit être adoptée puisque c est que
c'est un gouvernement minoritaire
et ensuite il faut signer les ententes
ce sont des arrangements fiscaux des
transferts fédéraux entre le fédéral et
le provincial mais je n'en sais
absolument aucun enjeu le premier
ministre trudeau a dit ce midi le québec
aura sa juste part mais les journalistes
lui ont beaucoup posé la question est-ce
que c'est sans conditions sans condition
il n'a jamais vraiment répondu
directement laissant entendre qu'il faut
une entente
donc il peut y avoir des conditions mais
je pense que les jeunes allaient se font
leur travail nommé juge aimerait
rappeler à tout le monde
nous sommes un rang digne d'une
troisième vague
il ya une récession il y avait des
bonnes nouvelles dans le budget et il y
en avait des mots est bonne et il y aura
un programme national de garderies
nous en avons déjà un au québec nous
sommes l'inspiration de leurs programmes
ils nous auront une compensation
financière et c'est une bonne nouvelle
il qu'elle lit vous faire de cette
compensation financière des 6 milliards
sur cinq ans d'abord nous sommes déjà en
action parce qu'on a déjà un réseau et
lors de notre dernier budget de 25 mars
nous avons dit que le principal problème
c'est la pénurie de main d'oeuvre alors
le ministre la ministre enseignement
supérieur le ministre du travail le
ministre la famille sont au travail pour
augmenter le personnel
ensuite ce que nous avons perdu durant
la pandémie ce sont des services de
garde en milieu familial
alors il faut récupérer ces places là et
bien sûr faut compléter les fameuses
places qui ont été annoncées qui sont
déjà financés mais qui n'ont pas été
livrés alors nous on est déjà en action
on est des gens
à s'affairer pour améliorer notre
rezzouki on va continuer est ce que vous
vous engagez est ce que c'est parce que
la somme de 6 milliards de dollars soit
investi entièrement dans le réseau des
garderies
non parce que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne on dépense déjà 3 milliards
de dollars pour notre réseau de
garderies
on va continuer à l'améliorer et ça
prend du personnel c'est pas juste une
question de dire on voit ainsi des
places il faut livrer les places et est
donc on va continuer d'améliorer notre
réseau et les sommes dues fédéral vont
nous aider c'est un des miens mais une
partie de cet argent pourrait aller
ailleurs que dans le réseau des
garderies exactement on prend bien
puisque le gouvernement fédéral juge bon
de payer aujourd'hui la moitié des frais
de garderie les provinces est-ce que
vous allez réclamer des sommes pour les
années passées où le québec avait son
système ni payée entièrement son système
mais je pense que l' enveloppe que le
fédéral accorde et fermer leurs scénarii
un budget pour l'initiative
c'est assez clair les montants sont
divulguées pour chacune des cinq
prochaines années et nous aurons notre
quote-part basé sur
le pourcentage d'enfants de 0 à 5 1 au
québec nous allons porter une
réclamation pour lee 10 20 années
passées
non non non je vous pose la question
parce que le principe il est là le
gouvernement fédéral dit on va payer 50%
des nouvelles garderies dans les
provinces qui vont décider de se faire
un système de garderie
nous sommes un temps qu'on a un système
de garderie qu'il fédéral au pot pays et
c'est le québec qui est payé pour ça
oui mais il faut faire attention aux
principes heures c'est bien d'avoir une
orientation du décret fédéral veut payer
50% mais dans les faits ce qui est un
autre site une enveloppe de 30 milliards
sur cinq ans il ya dix provinces et
trois territoires et chaque situation
sera différente dans le cas du québec
nous sommes l'inspiration du fait
d'erreurs alors ce sera un transfert
sans condition et donc ce soit un
transfert sans conditions mais vous
n'allez pas réclamés pour les années
passées des sommes dues fédéral non ce
n'était pas mon intention
votre plan de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire s'appuie sur différents
principes est l'un des principes dans
votre budget de 25 mars et une
contribution fédérale accrue pour les
dépenses de santé
y a rien dans le budget est à dire là
dessus est ce que vous êtes obligés de
refaire vos calculs pour revenir à
l'équilibré
non parce que nous n'avons pas inclus ce
que nous incluons dans le cadre
budgétaire du gouvernement du québec
c'est tout ce qui est confirmé par des
lois alors nous nous sommes confiants il
ya des discussions présentement au
niveau du comité des arrangements
fiscaux où nous faisons la démonstration
rétrospectivement et prospective mme que
le gouvernement fédéral n'en fait pas
suffisamment en santé et donc ultime ans
nous sommes confiants que le
gouvernement fédéral de reconnaître
qu'il doit en faire plus mais pour ce
qui est de notre cadre financier
il n'y a aucune augmentation
actuellement du transfert canadien en
santé et nous sommes déçus qu'il n'y en
avait pas fière mais nous allons
continuer à revendiquer
lorsque notre notre demande est légitime
mais vous le mettez dans vos principes
pour revenir à l'équilibré budgétaire
que les dépenses en santé du fédéral
doivent augmenter
donc vous vous attendez à de l'argent
les menteurs pour arriver à l'équilibré
budgétaire normalement lorsqu'on discute
des arrangements fiscaux j'éjecté même
le premier ministre trudeau à sa
conférence de presse ce midi il a dit
qu'il y aurait une discussion sur les
transferts en santé
ils veulent que séduction soit après la
pandémie
nous aurions aimé que la réponse vienne
dans le budget hier et c'est en ce sens
que nous sommes déçus mais pour ce qui
est des faits les faits sont indéniables
et vont supporter notre pulsion
merci beaucoup il s'agira merci d'avoir
été rythme non merci beaucoup pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit